es tu nicolas sarkozy avait annoncé que
tous les thèmes serait abordé il a été
interrogé sur son salaire sur ses
vacances et sur un possible mariage sur
ce terrain de la vie privée il a renvoyé
la balle aux médias michaël darmon
vivien roussel la question était sur
toutes les lèvres des journalistes à la
conférence de presse on la pose seins
sans tarder nicolas sarkozy et carla
bruni
vont-ils se marier avec carla nous avons
décidé de ne pas mentir ne voulons rien
d' instrumentaliser mais nous ne
voulions pas nous cacher je ne voulais
pas qu'on prenne une photo de moi au
petit matin
glauque et puis vous l'avez compris
c'est du sérieux
mais c'est pas le jdd qui fixera la date
les français ne parle pas que des amours
présidentielle il parle également de son
salaire qu'il a décidé de faire voter
par l'assemblée
après l'avoir aligné sur celui du
premier ministre dix neuf mille 331
euros nets
mais n'aime pas qu'on vienne le chercher
sur ce terrain et de surcroît j'ai moi
même demandé à ce que désormais le
président de la république ne puisse
cumuler retraites et salaires et six
volets une confidence à l'arrivée ça me
fait un peu moins que ce que gagner mon
prédécesseur
en cumulant retraites et salaires voici
ma réponse même fougue lorsqu'on évoque
ses liens avec l'industriel bolloré qui
lui prête son jet pour partir en
vacances là il rappelle les pratiques du
temps de françois mitterrand qu'est ce
qu'on préfère que je veux des place aux
frais du contribuable français et que je
fasse venir une seconde famille dans un
autre avion du contribuable français ça
ça vous choque pas bref nicolas sarkozy
a décidé d'assumer sa manière d'être et
de gouverner même s'il est conscient
qu'il casse les codes traditionnels
auprès des français bon